chennai índia
[Música]
a banda gaúcha
em israel
[Música]
ai ai
e aí galera que o planalto com você e eu
estou bem e essa música que eu acabei de
lançar não for limpo o web em um amigo
de genebra ele que fez aquela do justin
bieber também que eu toquei no vídeo da
invocação do mal se inscreve no canal da
web é o primeiro link na descrição do
vídeo é só clicar inscrever no canal de
lima junto à eb do nordeste também para
todo lugar que eu vou a pessoa pergunta
se um diz o que merda foi dito fez no
teu cabelo e aí eu vou explicar a
confusão parodi iuane é a conversa
sempre me sentar porque não corta então
porque não corta o cabelo porque eu
gosto de ter cabelo bigode tem muito
cabelo tem cabelo grande é que o cabelo
é feita em cortar é tem muita gente de
cara feia também ninguém cortou o
pescoço porque eu gosto de cabelo assim
que eu já fui criança e eu já tive hoje
eu vou contar desde o começo pra você e
eu já tive e hoje tive porque o que foi
que aconteceu estava de boné como sempre
assistir meu dragon ball quando ainda
tinha neco na faca bernardo tinha
roubado esse prazer da gente é isso
mesmo mundo à volta tirou o tv globinho
da gente deus fui lá e tomou ele é bom
aprender é que o jogo virou na mesma
cadeira e ele não duvide disso não sério
não por favor me dá problemas não vamos
de novo
estava eu assistindo ao treino bom né na
tv globinho antes da fátima bernardes
entrar com seu belíssimo programa
encontro com o fátima bernardes pessoas
enquanto dela e acabou com meus encontro
do último encontro com goku verde a este
programa da faca bernardes é cada vez
menor renda é muito bom fazer piada com
a verdade para o estava eu assistindo o
dragon ball só assistindo gol lá só
assistindo entre os comerciários e
passou aquela propaganda do ex cabo
esses caminhos caminhão remédio piolho
que tinha que a propaganda era muito
linda e e piano com essa casa com essa
casa pia' lipiani passar na globo scapin
e era um monte de menininha de cabelo
liso os cabelos em colocar de hoje e
amanhã lavando o cabelo do menino
não deu e não ficar com piolho baixaram
e capim e o menino sofre no piano piano
com a cidade nós gaza nem aquele
comercial falei isso não é um remédio
cumpre hoje o seu anti depressivos paz
felicidade com a família quando lavamos
cabeça tirando os piores junto e nesse
tempo da propaganda de descaminho tempo
de selar um surto de piolho no mundo eu
fui para a escola eu tinha um amigo que
tinha piolho e eu comecei a andar com
eles só pegar piolho de propósito eu
peguei piolho porque eu quis obra minha
mãe lavar minha cabeça que esse caminho
é beleza começou essa costa aqui com o
saco da cabeça e beleza eu vi que eu
tinha piolho cheguei pra mãe irmã e está
confiante em uma tarde lá da minha mãe
pegou essa menina pelo braço e saiu
correndo todo mundo precisou sair de
perto de mim eu não sabia se estava com
piolho é boa um toque de recolher minha
mãe voltou correndo já não tentes enfim
na bola pegou um pano baixou a cabeça e
olhar para a mesa e competir começou mas
também de toda a força da lei o deus do
céu e não tá cheio e olha o branco eu
não sei como é que ainda vou sair mas
como piolho era grande e me chamar de
burro remar em outra onde esse boi noel
principal era tanto boca para brincar de
vaquejada o pior no som esqueci sai no
peixe o pior são a rolândia o que além
de allende é a mulher do piolho ela que
pariu e essa é pior porque além de já
não sai no pent eu quero que minha mãe
fazia com prováveis cabe não mais e
assim vai acabar é que não é aqui
dançava eu adoro e onde é que a mãe quer
fazer isso é bem de casa na calçada de
casa no meio da rua que é pra todo mundo
ver que você tem piorou passando e ela
não tinha tal não mexe tava de ouro ela
também alega a empresa estado de lente
meu deus você quer que eu fale ou seja
pronta agora o skype em inglês por cinco
segundos e na minha mente até aquela
cena linda mãe coisa meu cabelo ofili só
coisa de cinco segundos só que logo a
realidade me acordava ou tomar banho e
eu tomei banho e pronta ela te arrumo
também pegou no meu braço e saiu
caminhando pela rua de gordinha na
farmácia pra esse caminho é bicheiro
elas também é chegou na farmácia mãe
passou da farmácia não talvez né tem
outra farmácia preço mais barato e foi
um influente fui mãe parou na frente do
lugar
mamãe trouxe me puxando eu olhei pra
cima da letra e um monte de gente
sentada o povo 1
os castings ouro mãe descreve seu hotel
está no zero
[Música]
amanhã vou raspar a cabeça caiu chorando
me sentindo em casa digna mesmo quando
fiquei cara que eu pude perceber um
tanto que minha cabeça era feia cabeça
acho que tinha caído muito quando era
pequeno minha cabeça cheia demonstrou um
curativo por aqui por aqui hoje fazer
motocross na minha cabeça eo caminhando
conversava a minha cabeça que era a hora
não é de tanto barulho em cima
demonstrou larga era muito feia mãe
tenta me consolar não meu filho fica
senão porque o ronaldo também é careca
diga uma coisa ronaldo secar é muita
coisa eu não sei cara e isso era uma
pessoa marcada e todo mundo sabia que
você tinha piolho naquele tempo se você
tinha cabelo e do nada você chega na
escola careca é porque você tinha piolho
e para criança é o seguinte não importa
se você não tem mais vai ser eternamente
o policial fala da puc o cara perde
amigo carregar na escola caic um bora
brincaram na mas que não vai diz que
quem mandava eu tinha um cara que tem
piolho era vira de tormento perfil mas
eu sairei do piolho não tinha mais nada
de boa cabeça começou a crescer de novo
normal voltei pra casa é um dia de boa
comecei a brincar com meu irmão chegou e
ir no abraço meu irmão não tem mãe no
tempo ou não eu vou estar com catapora
disse a ruta que pariu uma desgraça para
da otan criança e postou o vídeo não se
esquece clicar em gostei aqui no youtube
tava lá no facebook eu postei esse vídeo
vídeo novo piolho não sei o que lá
clique em curtir no facebook marca nos
comentários seus amigos que tiveram pior
quando era criança com um primo que teve
ou até quem teve um alguém próximo que
tem piolho um parente de bionic curti-la
no facebook metlife aqui no youtube está
aqui no youtube ele você comentasse aqui
embaixo nos comentários
o tubo foi a pior doença que você já
tenha o pior não é doença mas eu queria
que você comentasse aqui no youtube qual
foi a pior doença que você já tem quando
você era criança escreve o canal
nenhum vídeo novo 'tamo junto' galera
minhas redes sociais na descrição do
vídeo é nóis valeu br